si tuvieras una oración para decirle al
mundo algo realmente importante que
dirías
esta pregunta no solo te está costando a
ti me cuesta a mí también nos cuesta a
todos porque vivimos en una era sumida
en una crisis de contenido desde épocas
antiquísimas vivimos en un sistema de
silencio
en la edad media el feudo era la norma
entonces el rey y el noble y el clero
eran las tres aristas del poder y los
únicos habilitados para hablar pero para
hablar me voy a referir al ser
considerado públicamente como una voz
audible a tener el micrófono para este
punto de la historia de las 200 personas
que me escuchan ahora más o menos una
120 serían esclavos 20 serían mujeres 40
niños y 20 hombres pobres y todos
absolutamente todos seríamos socialmente
inválidos ninguno de nosotros soñaría
con tener el micrófono
adelantándonos a la época de ilustración
en el siglo 18 los eruditos los
filósofos los estudiosos se abrieron el
paso al club de las voces del poder
entonces teníamos la luz rousseau y
montesquieu tomando el té con el
gobernante y el noble y bueno tal vez
dos índole cada ser del clero en todo
caso ellos ahora eran parte de la batuta
de la gente que tenía el poder de hablar
nos adelantamos a la industrialización
en el siglo 19 entonces apareció el
oficio del empresario dueño de fábricas
explotadoras de jóvenes como tú y yo él
tenía suficiente dinero en su bolsillo
para comprar sus cinco minutos de fama
al micrófono él también puede hablar
ahora
el siglo xiv el siglo 20 realmente
cambió un poco las reglas del juego sus
dos guerras mundiales de una fría casi
helada cambiaron completamente cómo
funcionaba este sistema ahora solo
tienes voz si proclamadas y gritas por
los cuatro vientos el socialismo que el
capitalismo que el socialismo es la es
del camino entonces se desarrolló un
domino de dictaduras a nivel mundial en
el que no les fue suficiente con hacer
inaudibles públicamente a aquellos que
no estuvieran de acuerdo con el régimen
sino que desarrollaron todo un sistema
de exterminio para ellos entonces acabó
la vuelta de la esquina en chile tuvimos
tres campos de concentración pero por
suerte en un sistema puede durar por
siempre
llegó el siglo 21 pateando la puerta
grande con la revolución industrial el
empoderamiento juvenil y cuantos otros
fenómenos todo el tablero de juego se
dio la vuelta se produjeron micrófonos
de en masa como este en cada teléfono
inteligente y computadora y se crearon
los auditorios más grandes y eficaces en
facebook twitter instagram en realidad
incluso los estados reformularon todas
sus constituciones para basar las
alrededor de la voz del ciudadano por
eso hace un poco más de un mes acá en
ecuador la mayoría de ustedes votaron
por un consejo de participación
ciudadana o en argentina por ejemplo los
sindicatos de trabajadores tienen casi
el poder absoluto de detener el país con
un solo par
en la casa por ejemplo ya no tenemos de
esta jerarquización suprema del poder y
si tu tatarabuelo se despierta hoy entre
los muertos y ve que tú le tratas a tu
papá de manera que él jamás pudo haber
soñado probablemente se vuelva a acostar
en su tumba o en la escuela ya no
tenemos la cuestión retrógrada de que el
profesor te pega con la regla a la mano
sino que ya ni siquiera necesitas alzar
la mano para hablar porque en el sistema
educativo como holístico puedes en
realidad hablar cualquier rato porque
todo es un debate abierto entonces
hemos transformado nuestro sistema de
silencia en un sistema de habla y claro
todavía tenemos minorías que aún no
tienen acceso a esta voz aún y debemos
luchar para que sea así pero en realidad
la tendencia es que todo el mundo sea
audible les introdujo este término
cultura de remezcla a la teoría de
comunicación en general el con este
término lo que hacía referencia es a la
ruptura del esquema comunicacional
tradicional en el que sólo alguien digno
puede generar contenido válido para ser
compartido públicamente es decir con el
periodista puede crear noticias para
compartirlas con el público o solo el
cineasta consagrado puede compartir sus
películas con el mundo en cambio con la
cultura la remezcla todo el mundo puede
crear cambiar y pintar el contenido como
le plazca
cuántos de ustedes tienen un sticker en
su celular
cuántos de ustedes han creado el stick
cuando tienen un meme estos son
clarísimos de ejemplos de cómo funciona
la cultura de remezcla ya no nos
bastamos como utilizar los de móviles
por default en whatsapp sino que la
tecnología nos da el poder de crear los
nuestros nuestro propio contenido de
igual manera ya no necesita ser un
periodista profesional por ejemplo para
compartir una noticia en tu feed de
facebook ya no necesita ser un gran
productor de cine para publicar tu vídeo
producido caseramente en vídeo de hecho
así es como yo empecé mi productora
audiovisual a los 14 años ya no
necesitas la validación de los medios
para poner tu contenido allá afuera en
realidad es tan fácil publicar contenido
ahora que vivimos en un mar de
información 400 horas de vídeo se
publican por minuto en youtube y
facebook tiene 2.7 billones de usuarios
para la referencia el mundo tiene 7.5
sin embargo la mayoría de personas no se
quedan más de 20 segundos en cada vídeo
en línea y el 70% de las publicaciones
de instagram pasan completamente
desapercibidas es decir ni un solo like
entonces si vivimos en la época de la
información porque hay una crisis de
contenido donde está esta crisis de
contenidos
mi respuesta es en la calidad hoy vamos
a ver tres criterios para evaluar es el
primero la relevancia
sabían ustedes que la mitad de los
vídeos originales en youtube son de
mascotas
ahora ayuda con el verso que en sus
teléfonos y elijan su red favorita
facebook twitter instagram lo que quiera
van a ver las cinco primeras
publicaciones que les aparezcan puede
ser un meme puede ser lo que sea y
realmente pregunten si alguna de estas
publicaciones les cambia en algo
podrían seguir su vida podría seguir su
día sin haber visto estas publicaciones
yo creo que si en realidad mi creencia
es que vivimos en un mar de información
básicamente dispensable desechados
número 2 la originalidad si vemos el
perfil de facebook de cualquier persona
estos días y elegimos cualquier persona
al azar lo más difícil va a ser
encontrar un contenido original es decir
creado por uno mismo lo más frecuente es
que encontremos publicaciones o memes
compartidos de otra cuenta y que
simplemente tú les vas transferido a tu
cuenta
igual pasen fe en twitter con el retweet
estás pasando más tiempo compartiendo
los pensamientos de alguien más que
compartiendo los tuyos propios por eso
en las plataformas de ahora en línea
facilitan lo más posible el compartir el
contenido así no más de un año apareció
en instagram esta función de él
comparten tu historia con alguien más de
ti y que tenga suya entonces en realidad
no estamos generando contenido propio
por último la veracidad
en realidad si una publicación ha
probado ser relevante y original habrá
que ver si es verídica aquí es donde
entra el fenómeno de los baking news
algunos de ustedes revisa las fuentes de
lo que lee en línea
creo que me gustaría felicitar si es que
alguien alza la mano en realidad es
sumamente fácil crear contenido
publicarlo y realizarlo de hecho existe
un articulo trump 2016 presidente
gracias a las redes sociales de roberto
rodríguez en el que se expone como los
bake news potenciaron la campaña
política de trump en realidad se
publicaron páginas web fantasmas en los
que se publicaban noticias escandalosas
sobre clinton y uno diría bueno quién se
va a creer que hillary clinton mandó
asesinar a un agente del fbi pero
resulta que el 75% de las unidades que
vieron estas noticias las dieron por
verídicas inmediatamente
sí ya sabemos que el siglo 21 nos ha
dado una voz y que gente ha luchado
gente a sufrir y gente ha muerto por
tener esa voz y aún así vivimos en un
mar de voces pero ninguna tiene nada que
decir todos tenemos el micrófono ahora
pero pocos en realidad le damos una
razón
ya que vivimos en este mar de
información tendríamos que preguntarnos
de qué manera somos parte del problema
mañana cuando vayas al colegio
pregúntate qué porcentaje del tiempo
pasó haciendo crítico del ajeno y hoy
tarde revisa tus últimos chats y mira de
qué temas estamos hablando en ellos
estás diciendo las cosas que quieres
decir estás utilizando tu voz para lo
que en realidad deseas
sabes que quieres decir con tu voz
la buena noticia es que no tienes que
saberlo aún es normal no saber quiénes
somos a los 14 15 16
en realidad la pregunta en realidad para
nosotros sería quién queremos llegar a
ser recuerdo que cuando empezaba la
secundaria los consejos de los adultos
para todo en realidad era siempre solo
sé tú mismo pero para mí la decisión a
los 13 era o me pongo jeans o me pongo
ley y yo terminaba siendo una persona o
más de jeans o más de ley pero la
pregunta quién soy yo podría ser un
tanto más difícil de abarcar
entonces yo soy una fiel creyente de que
no se puede saber qué decir sin saber
quién se quiere ser entonces para
encontrar tu voz tienes que saber a
dónde tienes que llegar
hoy vamos a ver tres pasos para definir
esto el primero empápate de toda clase
de experiencias ahora que tienes 15 años
entra el club de ajedrez a las clases de
jugando al voluntariado a la fiesta de
la chica que te cae mal y dedícate
escuchar en realidad de escuchar no sólo
pretender hacerlo a todo tipo de gente y
si también cuando está velitas y queja
por enésima vez de nuestra generación
perdida hay una riqueza de conocimiento
exquisita allá afuera y quizá por
sentarte haber rico en muerte por la
enésima vez en el sillón te lo estás
perdiendo no dejes que la barra de
expectativas que tiene la sociedad de
nosotros jóvenes es bajísima de
condiciones no es suficiente con ir a
clases no es suficiente con sacar buenas
notas y no es suficiente con llevar un
plato cada cinco días
tú puedes más tú eres más
si te llenas de experiencias
eventualmente vas a tener un criterio
para definir lo que te apasiona lo que
te gusta de lo que no lo que nos lleva a
nuestro siguiente punto
encuentra tu brújula una vez empapado de
experiencias pregúntate por qué quieres
70 años más en el planeta o 27 si es
kurt cobain en realidad lo que debería y
arte es este por qué
una manera práctica de visualizar esto
es visualizarse a ti misma a los 80 años
y preguntarte tienes alguien al lado que
recuerdos vienen a ti cuando piensas en
tu vida
qué te gustaría que diga en su tumba
entre pitt hacia allí lo tienes número 3
una vez sabiendo a dónde vas a ir dibujo
un plan de cómo llegar para eso tienes
que considerar todos los barrios de tu
vida familia economía amistades etcétera
piensen cómo debe lucir cada área para
que puedas llegar a cumplir este por qué
y después dibujas del mapa básicamente
cómo vas a llegar pone todo tu esfuerzo
a cumplir esta guía pero si algún
elemento no funciona como cuando yo soñé
en irme a estudiar fuera del país solo
la dirección de louis sigue no pasa nada
hay muchísimo tiempo
ha sido mi oportunidad de utilizar el
micrófono pero ahora es tu turno acá
arriba tengo un fuere el que puedes
escanear con la cámara de tu teléfono
sólo tienes que apuntar y ahí tienes los
tres pasos que esto estoy y la pregunta
que quieres decirle al mundo
me interesa muchísimo saber qué clase de
mundo tú te puedes imaginar estas
respuestas serán parte de una
recopilación realmente muy muy grande de
lo que soñamos los jóvenes de hoy me
encantaría saber qué clase de mundo te
puedes imaginar
muchas gracias por esta oportunidad este
ha sido mi micrófono pero es el tiempo
que feliz es el tuyo
gracias